foreign
's YouTube channel in the session we
will learn how to use like operator in
SQL but before we begin let me tell you
guys that we have daily updates on
multiple Technologies if you're a tech
geek in a continuous hunt for latest
technological friends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and don't forget to hit that
Bell icon to never miss an update from
Simply learn now without further Ado
let's get started with our one point
agenda that is how to use like operator
in SQL so at first let's take a quick
look on the syntax that we will be using
for getting the like operator operation
right so it's really simple so all you
need to do is Select star from table
name so instead of star you can also
give your selected columns here but by
default I'm using to select the entire
table right and it can go with a where
Clause so after the table name you will
be given the where clause and the column
name that you want to extract and you
will be using the like operator with the
constraints and I'm using the single
quotes here right because this
particular like operation can be used
upon string or worker or character type
data types right so we will represent
that particular data type using single
code now that we are clear with the
syntax let's go to the Practical mode
that is the SQL workbench or MySQL
workbench and execute the like operator
command if getting your learning started
is half the battle what if you could do
that for free visit skill up by simply
learn click on the link in the
description to know more
SQL workbench and
consider the employee name so we have
some text or worker type of data type in
the employee name as well as the
employee Department right let's use that
particular data and here we have the
command and Select Staff from employee
table 2 where we can edit the same
command employee name
uh
like
and remember the single quotes right and
we will be using the percentage
operation here right we can give the
full name so we have Jennifer here right
Jennifer or let's remove Jennifer and if
somebody asks you give me all the names
which start with the G right in that
particular situation we will using the
modulus symbol or percentage symbol
right now what we will get is all the
names that start with the alphabet J and
now let's say we found all the names
that include a certain alphabet let's
say r
right then we can use the modulus symbol
again it can start with anything and it
can end with anything but it should have
alphabet R so this is how it works so we
have all the names which start or
include the alphabet are in them right
and that's how we can use the like
operator in SQL you can also use like
operator in this way where you can get
the entire name let's say somebody asks
you to get one single row which has the
employee name as Peter right you can
also do this in this way
there you go you have Peta choose from
over 300 in-demand skills and get access
to 1 000 Plus hours of video content for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more so with that we have come to
an end of this session on how to use
like operator in SQL if you have any
queries regarding any of the topics
covered in this session or if you
require the resources like the code or
PPT do let us know in the comment
section below and our team of experts
will be more than happy to resolve all
your queries at the earliest until next
time thank you stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here